prenez moi je te supplie on a eu quand
même prenez moi vous trouvez
merci
c'est comment j'ai très bien jamais elle
est arrivée m'a dit est arrivé face à
eva un pique nique
mardi achetez moi ouais non mais bien
les deux j'ai un costume 19 caisses g 14
piges il est sous la bestiole chez vous
hier il a encore asséné survêt famille
toute ta foi t'a il emporté sur 20
c'est lui qui fait le batteur
l'inquiète pas du genre à me changer
là c'est bientôt le moment
c'est vraiment comme un cadeau de noël
avant l'heure c'est magnifique pour le
film
au but de mettre la pression pour y
passer un sale moment
sur la nature à ses cinquièmes
antalgiques
annuler l
impressionnant jeu
rajoelina
la supporter
à
chaque jour par sa cible est aussi fait
beau dehors
vous à
dire
sur le territoire ça va être rock and
roll hall of fame à faire la moue
s'était posée
marhaba recevoir
trop spectaculaire ça je peux monter les
marches avec toi
oui
des amis qui est monté les marches qui
m'avait dit profil bien et que je viens
au micro regardez bien autour de toi ça
va être très rapide
quand le moment s'échappe un petit peu
m
le film a fait un peu de bruit c'est
superbe